Narrator:
YES, THIS IS DAVID MAYMAN
DEMONSTRATING HIS WILD SIDE
AND WOWING OVER 2 1/2
MILLION PEOPLE WITH THIS,
THE ONLY FULLY FUNCTIONAL
JET PACK IN THE WORLD.
I NEED TO GET A JET PACK ASAP.
Narrator: YEAH. SORRY, HAKEEM.
THERE'S ONLY ONE
OF THESE BAD BOYS.
WE JETTED OFF TO CALIFORNIA
TO MEET CHIEF DESIGNER
NELSON TYLER
AND PILOT DAVID MAYMAN
TO FIND OUT WHAT DROVE THEM
TO BUILD
THE BEAST OF ALL CREATIONS.
I WAS 10 YEARS OLD.
AND ON THE RADIO
WAS BUCK ROGERS.
AND HE CAME OUT OF A SPACESHIP,
PUT ON HIS JET PACK.
AND I FIGURED,
"I'VE GOT TO HAVE ONE OF THOSE."
I'VE ALWAYS WANTED TO FLY,
YOU KNOW, MYSELF.
SO I GOT INTO
SKYDIVING TO DO THAT.
THAT'S A LITTLE DANGEROUS,
I THOUGHT.
SO, HEY, LET'S TAKE UP SOMETHING
SAFE LIKE JET-PACK FLYING.
I MEAN, THE JET PACK IS --
IT'S SCIENCE FICTION
TO A LOT OF PEOPLE.
BUT IT IS -- IT'S TRUE.
IT'S HERE.
IT'S SITTING RIGHT THERE.
Narrator: BUT HOW DO THEY GET
THEIR JET PACK OFF THE GROUND?
WE'VE SEEN JET PACKS BEFORE,
BUT THIS ONE IS SPECIAL.
THIS ONE CAN ACHIEVE
A VERTICAL TAKEOFF
AND CAN FLY THOUSANDS OF FEET
IN THE AIR.
THE JB-9 IS MADE USING
A CARBON-FIBER CORSET,
WHICH IS STRONG ENOUGH
TO TAKE THE WEIGHT OF THE ENGINE
BUT LIGHT ENOUGH TO BE WORN.
THE TURBINE ENGINES IN THIS
JET PACK WORK THE SAME WAY
AS THE JET ENGINE
IN AN AIRCRAFT,
AND THE EXPLOSIVE FORCE
OF THE EXHAUST COMING OUT
OF THE BACK OF THE JET PACK
SENDS THE WEARER
IN THE OPPOSITE DIRECTION --
UP.
AS THE FUEL BURNS OFF,
DAVID'S RIG GETS LIGHTER,
WHICH MEANS HE CAN GO FASTER --
UP TO SPEEDS OF
100 KILOMETERS AN HOUR,
OR 60 MILES AN HOUR.
IT'S FUNNY. WHEN PEOPLE
HAVE SEEN ME FLY ON VIDEO,
THEY GO,
"MM. THAT'S INTERESTING."
WHEN THEY COME OUT
AND THEY FEEL THE VIBRATION
AND THE NOISE
AND THEY SEE ME TAKE OFF
AND, LIKE, DISAPPEAR,
THEY'RE JUST LIKE,
"OH, WOW."
Narrator:
BUT HOW DOES DAVID MANEUVER
THIS MAGNIFICENT MACHINE?
DAVID CONTROLS THE JET PACK
USING TWO HANDHELD LEVERS.
ON THE RIGHT IS THROTTLE,
AND ON THE LEFT
IS A TWIST GRIP FOR DIRECTION.
IT MOVES TWO FINS,
WHICH ARE UNDER THE JET ENGINES.
THEY'RE CALLED YAW WINGS,
AND BY DEFLECTING THE EXHAUST
GASES IN DIFFERENT DIRECTIONS,
IT PUSHES DAVID DIFFERENT WAYS.
BY CONTROLLING THE ORIENTATION
OF THESE TWO FINS,
DAVID CAN PERFORM SOME
IMPRESSIVE TRICKS IN THE AIR.
IF HE DIRECTS THE OUTPUT OF ONE
FORWARD AND THE OTHER BACKWARDS,
HE'LL SPIN IN PLACE LIKE A TOP.
BUT TO GO SIDE TO SIDE,
HE JUST HAS TO REPOSITION
HIS BODY
AND ADJUST HIS WEIGHT
TO INDUCE A TURN.
Wrigglesworth: DAVID CAN ALSO
PUSH FORWARD ON BOTH LEVERS.
THIS PHYSICALLY MOVES
THE ANGLE OF THE ENGINES,
TILTING THEM FORWARD
AND MAKING IT EASIER FOR DAVID
TO MOVE IN THAT DIRECTION.
TO BE THE JET-PACK GUY,
"A," IT WAS THE --
THE TECHNICAL CHALLENGE
OF ACHIEVING THIS
WHEN NOBODY ELSE HAD.
AND "B," IT'S A HELL
OF A LOT OF FUN TO DO.
I MEAN, HONESTLY, IT'S A BLAST.
IT'S FINALLY HAPPENED.
YOU KNOW?
HERE IT IS. HEY, EVERYBODY.
COME GET YOUR JET PACK.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT
ONLY A SUPERHUMAN COULD FLY.
FOR US, THIS IS THE FUTURE
OF PERSONAL TRANSPORT.
Wrigglesworth: JET PACKS HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN THE STUFF OF DREAMS,
BUT NOW, THEY ARE A REALITY.
AND IT LOOKS BETTER
THAN I EVER IMAGINED.